Hi, Candice.
Hey, Andy, how are you?
Oh, you know, I see. How are you? It's been a long time. I'm very, very sorry.
Yeah.
Yes.
It has, it has. I'm doing okay trying to...
get through the days and I'm sure you're aware we have several changes and some things that are going on here internally that we're working through, but it's all kind of, you know, sorting itself out.
Yes.
True, very true. It feels like April was just a blur and now we're on to April, on to May. So that's that. But yeah, I just wanted to meet with you, have a chat about how things are going. And again, right after this weekly business review, we're
Yes, yes, yes.
going to move forward with monthly. And then I think I need to schedule a QBR also since you guys joined us December.
Yes.
Yes. So I wanted you to actually see the progress that we've had since then until the first quarter of 2026 and where we're heading. So
Perfect. Yeah. We are.
Yeah, I want.
We're in a state of growth a bit here internally. We are hashing out some things that just aren't working and resolving those.
Mhm.
Okay.
And Angela has been...
so phenomenal. So phenomenal. She has helped us in a tremendous way. The responsibilities that she's taken on and just her ability to
Mhm.
To look at an issue and see the overall and not just, you know, attack this specific thing, but to attempt to resolve anything future has been, I mean, has been phenomenal. Yes, yes, has been, has been phenomenal.
Yeah.
Not a bad aid fix.
Yeah, never a Banmeet fix. It's for, it's for like a holistic view of things, right? That's where she's very, very great at. Appreciate that and love to hear it. I mean, every time she's very outgoing, you know, her personality already, currently. And every time that she doesn't know any
PH.
Yes, absolutely.
Mmh.
or probably having a difficult issue. She's always asking for help. That's one of the things that I love about her. She doesn't carry this as if I know everything. So that helps her a lot in so many ways. So she will try everything she could so that she can resolve the issue. So going above and beyond.
Yes.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Everyday.
Good to hear. All right, so let's move on again. This is the bi-weekly business review for the month of April. Same agenda, check in, highlights, action tracker, performance, way forward, and recap. And so I'm going to check in with you. How are things? I think we had a bit of a
check in already, but I wanted to also tell you that we just received that the code has been signed for Jericho. So we're moving forward with his onboarding Monday. So that would include knowledge transfer and training with Angela. So it's, we're thinking of.
Nice.
Right.
Just like what you and I discussed in the past, it's a month of training. And after that, then, you know, Angela's going to move on and then we're going to train her. And then after that, we're going to talk again about his current role within Brian Creek.
Hello.
That's great.
Sounds like a plan. Okay, perfect. Do you need anything from our side of the fence to create an account for Jerome? Anything at all? I can send it over to you.
Yes.
Um...
Onboarding details.
Yes, just send me his stuff that way we can we can get that started.
Name, email address.
Okay.
Sorry, that's what they come across. I just wanted to make sure I wasn't missing anything.
It's all right. Okay, I'll send that over. All right, so going into the highlights, Angela has been actively involved in server maintenance activities to successfully push updates across servers. To be honest with you, I miss doing that.
Whenever I see her, I was like, you know what, I've done those in the past, like in my younger years. But yeah, it just brings back memory and I love working with it. That's why I know that she's enjoying it as much as she can. After that, she has improved efficiency in ticket handling.
enabling faster closure of alert related tickets and better response in this incoming issues. And this is what we talked about in the past wherein the first try, she had a bit of a stumble, but she was able to get back and resolve it actually. But now it's been, you know, a bit of a seamless progression.
Okay.
to that point. So with the quality, of course, we just don't want fast closure. We want to make sure we keep the quality and she maintains that for us. So I just wanted to highlight that. Anything else you wanted to add? We're good.
Absolutely.
I know, I mean, I'm 100% along with this.
Thank you.
She's, I can never speak highly enough of her, but she's even gone as far as to what would have been a ticket resolved just because of, you know, it wasn't problematic at that time or it kind of like she did herself. She just, she's dope.
Okay.
deeper into it, even still, and is presenting that to the client. These are things that we're seeing. These are areas that we might be able to, you know, go ahead and take care of, so they don't call this issue later on. She's very informative all the way to the client, and I really appreciate
Ohh.
Mhm.
that outside of just support tickets from them. Anything that's coming over from the knock or a monitoring alert, advising them of, we have a power supply at one location. It hasn't gone down, but it's not, you know, and she went above to inform them.
Mm mhm.
at this like, hey, this is not a problem right now, but it's looking like it could be a problem. Let's go ahead and resolve this. And they were immediately on board, immediately signed the quote for the replacement part. And now we're just waiting for delivery so we can install. And so she resolved a problem that was never there as far as the customer was aware. And
Wow.
The.
Which is like the P in proactive.
That's just top, that's top tier to me. Yeah, that's just top tier to me. You can't ask for better than that.
Gotcha. I'll make sure that I highlight that through this month also for her. Wanted to make sure that she gets all the recognition that she deserves. Gotcha. Noted. Thank you so much. All right, so action tracker, I do, or we did receive the survey for March and April.
Absolutely.
Thank you very much for that. As for the NPS, have you received one? You should be able to receive a quarterly NPS from us. But if you haven't, let me know.
Yeah.
Id.
I don't think I have. If you could resend it just to make sure I didn't overlook it, but I don't think so.
Okay.
Sure.
Mhm.
Okay, I'll send one since I think they didn't, maybe they did not add you to their receiver F to MPS because you're in bi-weekly, but you should be getting that since you joined December. Yeah, I'll re-triggered it. I'll let you know once it's sent.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. All right, let's move on to performance analysis. So for billable utilization target, you know, 80% is our target. But I wanted to show you the March onto the first week of April. So she has picked on April 2nd, which is a total of 82%.
which is on her shift hours. This is very, very huge win for her because she's not dealing with a lot of tickets as bore over the back end, including alerts. So in the next few monthly service call that we're going to have, I would add here the alert tickets also.
I want to make sure that you see that on the report so that we just don't see the 37% of the things that she does on an available ticket, but we also see the other side of that, like the back end, the alert tickets, what does she do there, so that it would give justice on what she does on a daily basis.
Mhm.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then for March 23 and 27, she has been hitting like half of our billable utilization target, which is 80, which is a pretty good win. There's a dip on the last day, which is Friday. But again, it would make a lot of sense if we have the numbers for
for the back end. I think, do you have an idea when you'll be having that pride cage soon or not yet?
Mhm.
Simply because we had to, I've had to focus back in on some other things on this side. So we're still very much in the process of implementing everything. My goal is to have us actively in it by June. So that's where I currently stand with it. I'm hoping that we can kind of balance our results out here.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Mhm.
Soon.
That way it does allow some more time to get back into it. So that's June is my goal.
Gotcha.
Perfect. Understood. Thanks so much. So for now, we're just going to use the one that we have, and then soon enough, we'll be getting that dashboard from BrideGauge. Thank you. Oh, just in case you need anything, I think I mentioned it before, in case you need anything, building a dashboard, a gauge from BrideGauge. So we have a team that does that. Let me know if you needed to set up a meeting with them. I'll
I'll hook you up.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Gotcha. Thank you. Next is ticket closure and trend analysis. So overall, for the month of, well, last week of March and beginning of April, she resolved 33 out of 36 tickets, which is
a good win for her, very, very good win, an average of three tickets a day and close 91% of tickets. So I wouldn't even look at the target 8 tickets close per day because their resolution, meaning that he's on top of every ticket he does on
Ohh.
on the business hour side that he works or that she works. So I would give her this and I wanted to make sure that we continue in going this way. And again, just like under the utilization, I would include here also the other tickets that he has. On how we do that, we'll figure it out with Angela. I'll make sure that you see that also. So
We give her justice on her on her tickets daily.
Absolutely.
Any questions on it?
No, ma'am.
Okay, thank you. All right, way forward again, we're expanding Angela's involvement in that server maintenance infrastructure task to further build technical debt. And I just wanted to let you know that she love every bit of it. So yeah, she just, she likes the.
I love that. I love that.
technical aspect of it. She likes, even though we don't even admit it, myself, I don't even admit it, but I feel like we're wired for firefighting, Candice. I don't know. It's just different, right? It's like a different high if you get to resolve something that you were so afraid of doing.
Yes.
Yeah.
So I think that's where she's at currently and I love that for her. So we're going to improve on that soon after Jericho has taken over the things that she's doing so that she could focus on adapting and learning new things for her. Next is, just like I mentioned, onboarding Jericho on May 11th. So
Mm.
even though we haven't signed that code yet. So Angela and Jerome has been spending time a lot doing sidebar, shadowing, and of course, him finishing the boot camp also to make sure that, you know, she had or he had everything there is to know.
within the system and within MSP environment. How was that, by the way? How was the interview with Jerome? How do you see him?
It went really well. Yeah, it went really well. And Matt and DJ were also a part of the interview process. And unfortunately, the last part of that week, I became very ill. So the day of the interview, I was present, but I had no voice. So the boys had to had to speak for me. And I'm
Oh no.
I'm teasing them questions as trying to like be quick with it. So the flow of conversation wasn't like stilted and we've limped through absolutely. So I'm looking forward to communicating with Jerome and actually being able to communicate with him and him kind of get a feel of me because it was a, it was painstaking, but.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Mhm.
The guys did good. They were very helpful. And yeah, as soon as we finished the interviews, we immediately got on another call, the three of us. And I believe I reached out that same day. It was like we were ready to move forward. It was very quick.
This is.
Mhm.
Yes, you did.
because we very much liked him. Yeah, it was a, not having any voice and having the guys having to speak on my behalf was a little brutal. It was brutal.
Exact.
Very good.
So difficult.
I don't want to have that. I don't want to experience that, candid. But yeah, I had to, I had to like shoo people away from taking Jericho away from you guys because since the code hasn't been signed and I was like, nope, you can't look for other people.
PH.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Nope, you can't move on. Just trying to make sure we don't have any type of overlapping when it comes to this. So it's a good thing also that the other managers and I usually talk and ask our partners and our clients if we're going to move forward so that, you know, I do not want to go back again and...
I appreciate that. I appreciate that.
you know, choose people, especially if you like someone. It's going to be frustrating, right? So, great.
Yeah.
Yes, I really appreciated your patience with us because the guys had evolved that very next week. So they were in and out most of the week. And then DJ had, he was out of town again this week. So it's been trying to communicate in between some other things that were going on. And
Mhm.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
This.
And getting late night types of things, so I'm glad we, I'm glad that they were he was finally able to get assigned.
Mhm.
I gotcha. No problem at all. I'm happy to help you guys. And moving forward, also we have an ITBD holiday. That's the Memorial Day on the 25th. You guys have that also. Do you need both of them to be here on that day?
Mm-hmm.
I want to say no, but can I, let me, can I get back to you? Because I may kind of split the day between them if they, just so we have some coverage throughout the day. But I need to check on a couple things first. So let me get back to you on how we may handle the holiday.
Yeah, definitely.
Sure.
Sure, no problem. And to be honest with you, I would love to have them there so that they have the entire day to train, because Gary goes to long training. So.
Kip.
Yeah, no, we can definitely work something out there. Like, so let me see. I'll get back to you this week on a definitive for that so it's not last minute.
Sure, no problem.
Gotcha. Oh, no problem. All right. Oh, before we go here, I just wanted to let you know also that you haven't seen Rodge very much recently, right? So he's not out of IT by design, not really out. He's still here, thank God. It's just that he has moved on into a more senior role.
As in.
That's very good on him. But today I was supposed to introduce you to the new team lead. However, he got into a motorcycle accident. That's why.
Oh, I hate that. Is he okay?
Yeah, he's okay now. Was able to talk to him on the phone. He should be okay. So next week, once you have a time, let me know so that I can have that catch up or maybe during our QVR, I can do that. So it will be Angela and him have met, by the way. So they have that. Hi, hello, catch up. What do you need?
Oh, good, good.
how can he help you and all the other stuff. So he's been in the business for, I think, 12 years now. So not just assisting engineers, he also covers their schedule, doing incident management, after hour support, everything of sorts, which is in line with the
OK.
what we're doing in Ryan Creek and how we can support Angela and Jericho moving forward. So yeah, I would love to introduce him. I'll still be very much your POC if you need anything in order to find me. Just holler and I'll be here. Okay.
Yeah.
I appreciate that. And give Rodge my best. I'm glad that he's advancing and that's I'm very happy for him.
No problem.
Mhm.
I will let him know. He said he was going to miss you guys, especially this type of golf. So, you know, Candace, there's just a lot of, you know, partners that we work with on a daily basis. And sometimes, to be honest with you, this golf, it's not even a pressure anymore. It's a breath of fresh air. And that's
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
So nice. Yeah, it is. It is. Just wanted to let you know that it's not always about the engineer or us. It's sometimes it's really about the Partner as well. So I just want to thank you.
Thanks.
I appreciate that.
You're welcome. All right, moving on. We have built it. So we have built it live 2026. I'm not sure if you've heard about it. So it's a big thing in happening in New York, in Jersey City. So it's August 3 to 5. A lot of attendees, a lot of MSP, a lot of AI innovation.
Mhm.
that will be happening here. So I would love you guys to attend since this is your first with us. I think there is another place that they are thinking of doing this in New York Stock Exchange. So it's a bit fancy. So
It is. That's very fancy.
So if you wanted to join, let me know if you wanted to attend. It will be a fun day, fun filled day. I think on the last day of Build It conference, they're going to deep dive into more of AI. So if you haven't...
haven't gone through that yet or don't know how to even start for your organization, it would benefit you guys.
Mmh.
be interested in for sure.
Sure. If you, I think we have a promo of BOGO, buy one, get one. So if you need that, let me know. I can give you that code. So I'll send you an email. If you want me to pass it along, let me know so I can send it.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
See, I personally love a good conference. I like to be in the environment. I love those. I know they could be daunting to some, overwhelming to others, but I personally, I love a good conference. So yeah, to send me the information, I'll definitely pass it along.
Mhm.
Yes.
True.
Will do, will do that. Thank you so much. All right, you know, Team GPS, if you wanted to have like a demo, let me know. It will help your...
Ohh.
Team one-on-one meetings, engagement, client management, and even CSAT if you don't have it any. So you can do that. Team GPS. And yeah, I think that is it. Thank you so much for your time. Before we go ahead and wrap it up, anything that you needed from my side?
Anything at all?
I don't think anything right this second.
Uh-huh.
I do want to apologize. I know that it probably comes across like we are very disorganized. We have a lot of internal things that are that are happening and changing and we're and I know that I've spoke on this before, but we were in the Ryan Creek is basically built up of Ryan Creek, the MSP side, but we have
It's OK.
Mhm.
Another company launched broadband that is, it's NDU, it's called Multi-Dwelling. And they do a lot of infrastructure, apartment communities, like whole networks and infrastructures for.
Yeah.
Mm.
multi-dwelling units. They have recently merged. As of May 1st, we are now actively one company launches is building or functioning under the Rhyme Creek brand. So there's just been a lot of that kind of happening internally.
Mhm.
Ooh.
how to seamlessly sync the two because we do have clients.
Mhm.
I'm not sure if you're very familiar with like what a multi-dwelling unit, like how that functions.
The or the structure of it, no, but I think when you say it got combined, is this happening as an M&A also?
Yes, so on the property level, we provide, you know, a network to the property as a whole, and then that trickles down to each individual location, right? So we may have a specific person as having an issue without the whole property itself having an issue, right? So that customer may call in, and it could be something as simple as they just need to simply reset a wireless router or
Mhm.
Mm.
Yeah.
power cycle it for some reason without it actually being a whole problem on the larger scale. So kind of integrating how that's going to flow into our day-to-day because it is it is the same in that it's all the same type of equipment that's being used. They're familiar with the unified site. Angela is unified site and kind of how it looks.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Mhm.
but now we're getting down to an actual unit level. So it's being able to clearly see what's happening on this port at this switch for this person. And so trying to see how that's going to seamlessly work into their day-to-day on top of working tickets.
Okay.
on the MSP side that are just a little different, you know, working for...
Yeah, so is it, is it more of a consumer side if it's happening on a specific unit kind of?
It.
It is, it is without that specific consumer being our actual customer, right? Because the property itself is the customer and, you know, they're paying for the right to access our service, but we will provide a service to them individually. It's kind of how that works. So
Mmh.
Contact, yes.
Yeah.
Exactly.
De.
As of May 1st, the two companies are combined in one. So it will not change their, you know, Angela or Jerrica's really day to day in any kind of large capacity.
Mm.
Mhm.
But we are working through figuring out how the best way to work that is going to look. So that's kind of a change that's happening with us internally. We are, Angela and myself are using the launch kind of customers as the guinea pigs in building the PSA.
because it is different. So I handle all of those customers independently, the way that they call in and I work with them independently. So we're guinea picking them into the new PSA. So when we move the Ryan Creek customers over, any kinks that we've had, any issues we ran into, we can all resolve those immediately.
Mm.
Mhm.
True.
Yes.
And the customers are aware that they're being used as guinea pigs, which is the best, you know, in my opinion. Right, no better way. So that will, their tickets will increase a bit, but, and when I say that, it might be one or two. It is by no means an extravagant number, but it is just a little different than what they're used to doing.
Yeah.
Transparent, yes.
Mhm.
But at the same time, it may not be, you know, power cycling a router is not a whole, not very different from power cycling a NAS, right? You know, so it's just who you're dealing with might be a little different.
Different, yes.
True.
And I think a strong, a very strong knowledge base is a key to those because it's...
It is, it is, because it also it cuts down on the on-site as well. And it allows our team to focus with the actual infrastructure opposed to having to physically send someone out to just go power cycle someone's personal router, you know. So yeah, it's going to be a little different, but
True.
Yes.
Exactly.
honestly, is probably going to be those easy breath of fresh air type tickets where they're like, okay, nice, nice, nice. I can just breeze through this. Yeah, yeah, it's going to be those for them. Absolutely. So that's happening for us. So we're using that company as the guinea pig is building the PSA and
Yeah.
Okay, I like this. I'll take this.
Mhm.
Cool.
Mm-hmm.
Angel has been a huge help getting the API keys and, you know, everything enabled and synced up properly. She's been a huge help on that side of it.
Mhm.
Perfect. So I think I'm not, I'm not sure if she's actually tracking her time in those. Do you guys use like an admin, I think, admin time, daily wrap?
So we're...
So she she has because we already used the connect was for our RMM. She already had her credentials. So she's in the system now. But we should be like creating a ticket of the time. And we have done that for specific. So like we do have a ticket, you know, for calendar syncs, email syncs, those types of things.
Mhm.
Anything that she has had ahead in helping, she has had a ticket to kind of base some time off of. So again, they're not billable. That's definitely falls in that, you know, back end type of work. But she has had something that she can kind of house her time and her energies into to document.
True.
Mhm.
Cool, that's good. Once you fully move into ConnectWise, really, I think I still have that training I created in the past. I'll send it over to you just in case, you know, it helps. It's more of ticket hygiene and tracking time because, you know, not just...
Yeah.
some of the engineers, but most of the engineers does a lot of work, but because they don't track it correctly, it doesn't justice. It doesn't give justice to what they do on a daily basis. So those are the things that they keep in my back pocket because I know that it's going to be handy anytime. So.
Mm.
Absolutely, absolutely. I'll definitely take anything you got. I did all of the webinars, but it was very much finishing up the webinars, getting sick, end of the month. So even myself, like, you know, with refreshers would be
PH.
The.
Mhm.
Oh my god.
would be great. I'm slowly trying to trickle back into the university and refresh my mind and going through all of my notes and things. There's we just we have a lot of moving parts happening here on our end. But you guys have been phenomenal. You guys have been phenomenal. Angela has been
Hmm.
I'll find it for you.
Yeah.
That's okay, completely fine.
phenomenal. I very much look forward to working with Jerome.
Just like a guy, good plug, dig it along.
I could, yeah.
I could not have asked, you know, to be provided with a better team. You guys have been stellar and I'm very appreciative. And I really look forward to diving in and with Jerome getting to know him, him getting to know me since he doesn't have a firm of reference for that currently. So I'm looking forward to that first day of having the conversation and
Very much.
And being able to, uh, to actually, you know, meet, and yeah, right, right.
Neat. Speak with him. Literally speak with him. I gotcha. I know here.
So yeah, I look forward to next week.
Yeah, me too. I'll send you over his details so that we can get his credentials sorted. And if you need anything, you know, Candace, I'm just one chat away. And I would wish you to have like a, I don't know, a vacation. I don't know how can that happen. I wish you some rest time. You need it and you deserve it.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you, thank you. I do plan to step away at some point, but right now I need to make sure, I need to make sure my team is, that they're comfortable and they have where they need and there's no vacation if you feel like you've left.
You should.
They can handle it, yes.
to your people, you know, struggling in any kind of way. So once I can get them settled, that's, I'll definitely take me a couple of days.
True.
That's what I call a leadership success. When you can leave them and they're okay, that's that. Very good. Yes, very much. Thank you very much, Candice. Appreciate your time always. Yeah, just let me know if you need anything. Happy weekend.
Yes. Yep. That's it. Doing something right.
That sounds great. Thanks, Andy. You too. Bye.
Rest of all. Bye.